thank you so much too thanks for
everyone coming today it's a nice big
group and it's been honored to be asked
to speak to an institution that has such
an amazing reputation i think for
technical excellence and also for an
entrepreneurial spirit especially on a
topic that isn't always associated with
those two things but I hope today to
talk to you a little bit of why it
should be and certainly can be I did
want to start with a slightly
unconventional question of all of you
and and and bear with me here so
everybody in this room have health
insurance can you raise your hand if you
have health insurance and if I'm
embarrassing you I apologize so most
people here are filling the sooner you
get health insurance um so sort of what
I expected I will tell you why I'm asked
that question a little bit later in in
in the talk so so bear with me I am the
sort of story of why I'm asking that
starts here and this is the offices of
Code for America we're on ninth Street
in San Francisco probably looks to most
of you in the audience like a tech
startup that's sort of what it is it's
got that kind of environment but as Tina
just noted last year I spent sorting in
june 2013 I spent a year going to work
at this office looks a little bit
different and the culture is a little
bit different this is the executive
office building in the White House
complex so that black fence that you see
there is is the border you actually have
to go through the metal detectors that
Secret Service run in order to get into
that building which means you going out
to lunch is much more complicated than
it is here and I I went and did this
year of service in our federal
government because of a man named Todd
Park who at the time and tell very
recently was the chief technology
officer of this country he was the
second person to hold that position and
he asked me to come help him run a
program called the presidential
innovation Fellows program is designed
to bring some of the best and brightest
from the private sector into government
for these year long tours of duty where
they would as it says innovate and it
was based
the program that I created at Code for
America but to do this in a federal
level and I eventually said yes to him
but only after saying I think it is
great to bring people into federal
government to do this kind of work but I
think we have a bigger problem that we
need to solve and it is that we are
spending truly staggering amounts of
money taxpayer dollars his numbers are
obviously a bit outdated hello it's 2015
and this was an estimate from a couple
of years ago but just in contractors
something in the order of 172 billion
dollars a year for IT that runs art
essentially a relationship between
governments and citizens but what we're
getting for that are websites that look
like this that are very confusing that
have a lot of legal language on them
that often break that you have problem
you may have encountered this is just
one screenshot from a project I worked
on in federal government and they often
don't work and what people's experience
of government mostly looks and feels
like is waiting in line because the
technology doesn't work maybe we can't
go online maybe the systems that are at
the DMV aren't working very well but
we're paying very large sum of money for
results that just simply don't match
what I told tad when he asked me to come
to federal government with it if you go
outside the US this is starting to be a
solved problem there is a group in the
UK called the government digital service
it is run by a remarkable man named Mike
Bracken who was formerly the head of
digital for the guardian newspapers and
he has brought together some of truly
the best and brightest in the digital
world in the UK to make government
services walk they started by putting up
something called google UK they looked
across their equivalent of a federal
government had found as we did there are
thousands and thousands we actually
think in federal government's about
30,000 websites where the government is
publishing information and
Hosting transactions that they think
that the people need but it really if
you have to your experience is really a
not a useful one if they hold all of
those together and put them under one
domain I know that it looks a little bit
like yahoo in the 90s but it turns out
based on user need this is a great way
to get people to the information that
they need so they started by basically
fixing the publishing aspect of what
they do simplifying the language
throwing out the vast majority of web
content andrey publishing a modern
platform and then they moved on to
transactions where they're able to
actually make these transactions that
you need to do with your government very
simple and easy to do we don't have
carers allowance here but think of it as
equivalent to a benefit that you might
get if many of you are too young to be
applying for Venice with its federal
government other than your student loans
if you have them but you probably if you
have student loans have been through
pages that look much more like what I
showed before then these very simple
clear transactions that simply work and
what I told him also was that this
actually this far increased experience
that the British citizens are having
with their government doesn't cost more
it costs much much less so it was
costing about a six to publish that
content on you got you k to have far far
more users of that content than what
they were doing before and that's before
they actually got to the transactions so
I pitched onimous idea that we need to
have an American equivalent the American
GDS and could we could we work on that
in my year in government and he was
graciously agreed and so I went to DC
and worked in that building for a year
on this for several months getting
sweaty people were pretty excited about
it and then October first came around
October first 2013 you guys probably
don't remember it but that's the day
that healthcare.gov launched and failed
so my work stopped for a bit my boss
disappeared he was asked to pull
together the team that was going to
figure out if the site was savable and
in fact save it this is some of that
team they ended up on the cover
Time magazine that's Todd hiding there
in the back because he's very shy and
doesn't like the spotlight right in
front of him are 2x Googlers Mikey
Dickerson who really ended up sort of
leading the team that fixed the current
site the site that the contractors had
built kind of with duct tape sort of get
it through the enrollment period and
then next to him Jeannie Kim who put
together the team that rebuilt the site
with a team of about 12 people over
three months something that had taken
several thousand people and about 600
million dollar taxpayer dollars to do
and didn't work she rebuilt with a team
of 12 in about three months I got to
know this team really well I feel very
privileged to have gotten to know them
there were many many late nights at the
office and in fact one thing that you
should know if you ever meet these folks
or many there many other folks who are
not pictured here obviously that I asked
my key once how many hours did you work
and he had was actually a subcontractor
to a subcontractor to the main
contractor paid hourly for his work on
making healthcare gov can't make it
through the enrollment period so he
could add those up pretty clearly and he
said I looked at it at one point I had
worked 20 hours a day straight for a
hundred days 400 days straight that's
heroism and I think almost all of the
people who worked on that team did that
and if you ever meet them please thank
them for their service to this country
because that's quite a feat and one of
those late nights I was we were we were
talking in the office about why they
were doing this incredible work and Todd
was getting the letters that were being
sent to the president about you know
from people who were benefiting from the
Affordable Care Act which is what
healthcare gov was implementing and
there were many men are many of these
letters and I remember some of them and
I remember that all of them had a deep
impact on me but one that I remember in
particular was from a mall
who said that she her family had a
history of diabetes and cancer but for
the past 15 years she had had to choose
between health care for herself and
health care for her kids and that the
ACA had meant that for the first time in
15 years she had gone to see a doctor
and that's why these guys were working
20 hours a day for a hundred days
straight and that's why I asked about
health insurance because it is really
hard to understand the really difficult
problems that we face as a country if
you don't experience those things
yourself and there's very limited
opportunities for us to be in that line
of fire yep many of us come from
backgrounds to do have it where we don't
have health insurance but if you do you
need to have opportunities to be aware
of the problems that our country faces
there was another time that we were an
office very late at night when the guys
were actually going back to the
operation center in Columbia Maryland at
about two in the morning and I said guys
you gotta go to sleep sometimes why are
you going there in the middle of the
night and they explained to me that in
fact there's pretty high traffic at how
on health care go this is about November
December there's pretty high traffic at
healthcare.gov in the middle of the
night but not from desktop browsers from
mobile browsers the people were hitting
the site in large numbers on low-end
mobile phones and the pattern was that
they would cut they would get online a
particular user would get online in the
middle of the night make it about two
steps further in the process of
enrolling in healthcare save his her
progress and go back on the next night
and at what you're seeing in that moment
is using looking at that data and seeing
real users who have real needs those are
people probably who are working more
than one job who obviously don't have
internet access at home and this was the
only way that they could navigate this
really difficult and complex site and
this complex process but they were going
to spend a couple of hours every single
night when they knew the traffic was
lower to just get a little bit further
with it
i think the lesson to learn here of
horus at first is that if you want to
recruit some of the best technologists
in the country give them something to
work on that really matters and they
will succeed they will not fail at their
test these guys were amazing and what
they did they think the second lesson is
sort of grimmer which is that however
you may feel about a policy like the
Affordable Care Act do we really want to
live in a world where we can't actually
implement the policies that government
creates whatever policy that might be we
almost lost the Affordable Care Act
because we could make a website work
something that probably many of you in
this room could have done quite well and
there are a lot of reasons why that's
true but that is if that is a place I
think of fundamental anxiety as a
culture and that's why it drives a lot
of the work we do and the third lesson I
think from healthcare gov is that this
was headline news of course for many
many months at least for many many weeks
primarily because it was the president
key policy initiative but also because
the middle class was having to use this
site and in fact if you are poor you're
kind of using something like
healthcare.gov every day as recline put
this very very well at the time and Tim
O'Reilly wrote about this as well and
I've been a post called what's really at
stake in interfaces to government but he
says he says you know most of the time
we just don't even know about the pain
and trouble of interfacing with
government bureaucracies that the poor
struggle with every single day and of
course it's not just the poor this is a
famously entrepreneurial community so
many of you will either have already or
will go on to start businesses and when
you do you also will be dealing with
filing things like business permits and
the sort of morass of things many times
your lawyers will be doing it but you'll
know a little bit about some of that
pain of dealing with government
bureaucracy in the forms that are needed
to fill out and it's really that sort of
more day-to-day frustration that drove
me to start code for america but
inserting it put me on that path to
underst
and some of really what's at stake in
our country and then sort of brought my
work at the local level and the federal
level together for me so I thought what
I do is take a little step back and tell
you about about Code for America and a
little bit about how it got started and
some of what we've learned over time
this is our first class of Code for
America fellows that came together in
the beginning of 2011 so these are folks
with several years of experience in the
industry average age of our fellows tend
to be up 29 or 30 but recent grads are
more than welcome to apply it could take
a year out of their careers to give a
year of service to their country and we
match them with local governments who
want to try things in a more startup
sort of spirit and with a very very
structured program I could tell you a
little bit more about that in 28 but i
think i'll tell you more about sort of
the work that we've done one of the
first things that happened we had a team
working with the city of boston in 2011
we actually went in to work on a sort of
data platform for education in the
Boston Public Schools which at that time
in our existence was very hard for us to
get access to data the movement of open
data and sort of trusting data to be
outside the walls of an institution was
a little bit younger than but so they
were fumbling around with this sort of
very grandiose project of an API for all
Boston Education data when the mayor
lovely may or may he rest in peace he
was a fantastic mayor in Boston came to
our fellows and said we have a really
big problem we have changed the rules
about how kids get assigned to public
schools it's essentially now around
trying to have more kids be able to walk
to school so it's essentially a mapping
problem and a couple of other rules in
there but what we've done is published a
28-page printed brochure with type that
small and sent it to all the parents who
are now in tears because you can read
the 28 pages of four point type and you
still have no idea which schools your
kids are eligible to attend can you help
us and so one of the fellows was working
on this API said I can't let me take
this and when
and about eight weeks later he published
I don't have the slide of the early
version this is that what it looks like
currently he published something called
discover be fiesta or put it up on a I
think on amazon and it's basically you
type in your name the age of your grade
that your kid in and if you have any
siblings the kid has any siblings in
another public school you get put your
address in it returns a map list of
where you can go to school so it takes a
very long process down to a couple of
minutes um great fantastic that's pretty
easy to do but what we learned in that
process we were like okay what do we do
next the folks in city government came
to us and they said you didn't
understand if this had gone through a
regular procurement process this would
have taken us at least two years and
costs at least 2 million dollars and I
don't think we actually realized that at
time at a time because what we were
saying what we were trying to say to the
world with look these interfaces to
government can be simple beautiful and
easy to use we can have a relationship
with government that says delightful and
positive is we have with other
institutions through that are mediated
through digital technology um but the
other thing that really got me about
that was it wasn't really about the
money it was about the time imagine
being the mayor and having to go to
parents and say yeah we'll get you that
into here you know in the meantime your
kids are trying to enroll in school so
this really set a pattern for us of
there's there's data that needs to be
made usable to a certain set of users we
can we can do that pretty easily we can
put a nice front end on it and it costs
kind of what it should cost in the real
world the team that did one of the guys
who was on the team that did that went
on to work on a problem what we just
discussed this idea of business permits
if you go to start this was reviews case
here really was a small business not
necessarily a tech startup in Santa Cruz
California where they were realizing how
difficult it was for someone to start
say a dry cleaners and all all of the
different forms that you need to fill
out they need to be filled at a
difficult or der you don't know how much
each form what he's come with each form
suppose you're throwing up their hands
and actually not complying with the law
say fight of service simp this is an
early early version of something called
open counter or they said you know we're
just going to start by explaining the
process to people and they first wanted
to make it human this is where we
learned about just changing from a very
bureaucratic language to a very human
language these are the people you're
going to have to go through we're not
changing that but here they are and
they're real human beings they're open
by the way their office hours are seven
a.m. to 12pm so hope you don't have to
go in the afternoon weeks described a
little bit about the process it became
sort of a a wizard and there was a point
at the process where you would then had
to you to applied for a number of things
and then you also had to go through a
zoning clearance you guys know what that
is zoning and it was when the part where
your users would typically show
frustration now I've got to do a zoning
check as well I don't why am i why am I
being required to do this and just some
basic language that tells you zoning
basically make sure a rubber factory
that would maybe put out toxic goons
can't open next to a preschool this is
why government exists and sometimes we
need a brief reminder of it as we're
going through a difficult bureaucratic
process um this actually has evolved now
this is screenshot from an application
that this team has done now turned into
a real business called zoning check so
whereas you would have to go through
lots and lots of different documents and
information to try to figure out where
you could place your business now you
can just click on palo alto i'm going to
open an office i don't know where i want
to be just show me where i could and
then it'll give you the you know the
green spots I assume that's university
avenue that little bit of green spot
there there you go we make we make
something much much easier to do we can
do this we can run this play hundreds
and hundreds of times but that that
really is what we think of as this
notion of let's make government work for
the people it's not that hard we just
knew really need to do it but that's not
all to this all there is to the story
because the history of our country
doesn't just talk about government for
the people it's also built into our
narrative a historic
narrative but it's also government by
the people and I want to tell you a
little story that illustrates the power
of that these were the fellows who were
assigned to our Honolulu project see we
go great places in in 2012 and in fact
sheba najmi at the top there is a
relatively recent Stanford grad who came
to us um and in Honolulu our city
partners there were asking us really to
fix their website which was tens of
thousands of pages of content backed by
no CMS and that was not something that
three folks could do in the space of one
year realistically which is the the time
frame of our fellowship so they kind of
kept saying I'm sorry that's not
something we can do let's find another
project but both the residents of
Honolulu and the people in City Hall
kept saying please please please fix our
website so they said let's start with
the problem this was the website at the
time it's a pretty classic government
website it starts up in the corner with
government agencies and departments
online services and the big chunk in the
middle is dedicated to news releases so
we call this like a very typical this is
what government wants to tell you it
doesn't have a lot of relationship to
what you need from government but it's
what we want to tell you so they said
okay if we care about what the user is
actually need let's look at the search
logs and they went in there and said
what are the top terms turns out the top
search term was driver's licenses which
is not an anomaly very often American
Americans do not understand which level
of governments does which function but
in this case Honolulu actually does
handle driver's licenses for the state
of Hawaii they said okay great let's put
that in there if you type driver's
license into the search box at Hanukkah
you will get a page that looks like this
there's actually does it about a dozen
pages that look like this you will click
through one of one of these and you will
get another page that looks like this
and this is something that tells you
that expired driver's licenses of a
member of any component of the United
States Armed Forces who's on active
federal service gets an extra 30 days
it's stuff like that dozens and dozens
of pages that look like this that
you not actually tell you how to get a
driver's license and so they decided
that what they could do is just first
show what's possible and they borrowed
from that gut UK site i showed you
earlier a very basic search interface
and they said look let's not port all
that content onto a noose and mass
that's a fool's errand but let's type
drivers let's create our new context you
type driver's license into this hon a
little answers interface you'll get
something like this if you click that
second link you'll get a page that says
how do I get a driver's license I need
to go here I need to bring these things
I need to take an eye test I need to pay
a fee and here's how I schedule my test
boom done this is the content that
people are looking for and this is not
as you can see a technology problem it's
a Content problem but the technology is
a part of it but they knew at that point
that there was still those tens of
thousands of pages of content that they
weren't going to tackle and tens of
thousands well maybe not ten thousands
of knees that the residents of Hawaii
had that were not being met by the top
10 search terms that they create a great
content for so I assume everyone here
has been to a hackathon is anybody here
before been to a right athan yes not
fair Tim we know that I believe that the
right athan that the coke america
fellows held in honolulu was one of the
first ever I now hear about them around
the country but what they did was they
took the questions implied by the next
70 search terms of 70 most frequent
search terms on the site and they put
them up on a wall in a co-working space
near City Hall on a Saturday afternoon
and they invited the people that they
had met through their research both
people in city government and just
concerned citizens and about 60 people
showed up and they spent the day writing
in clear simple human language the
answers to those 60 questions they would
edit each other's work and they would
check all of their work with the folks
in City Hall to make sure they weren't
saying anything technically inaccurate
and at the end of the day they had
questions to definitely through the top
of a long tail curve of
what people were coming to honolulu gov
asking and it was clear and simple that
in a way that their other fellow
Honolulu residents could understand and
most importantly they had an amazing
time they actually had a party and a
party with the mayor coming by and
celebrating is not what most people
think of when they think of government
technology and one of the real lessons
that we learned there which dr. Selig
alluded to in in my speaking of my TED
talk is that we have come to the
understanding that there's so many
concrete wit ways now that we need to
redefine participation in government
it's not just about having a voice in an
issue there are so many voices it's
about offering your hands to actually
fix the problem and I think we are at
the verge of being able to say there is
no excuse for complaining we can create
ways that we the people can fix these
problems another lesson that we learned
from Honolulu answers was that this
stuff can spread there are about a dozen
cities now that have a version of it
including where I live and where Tim
lives in oakland california we created
Oakland answers in the same format we
held a right athan near City Hall one
day and in fact this is the question
that I first question that I answered I
keep chickens in my backyard in Oakland
and I wanted other people to know that
they could do that I am by the way not a
programmer so this was a great way for
me to contribute a way for anybody who's
not technical to contribute to
government IT and Tim answered a great
question to and other dozens of cities
that are using it in fact there are
federal agencies that are using this
core technology as a way of just simply
publishing clear simple information to
their users so you start to think about
the ways in which it's not it this
really does start to look more like not
in text and Internet start-up but that
this is really working like the internet
itself solutions can come from anywhere
you do not expect you that work and they
can start to spread with a lot less
friction than we
usually associate with government
technology so that was really our sort
of getting that there is this top-down
and bottom-up piece to this solution
government needs to work for the people
but it's only really going to work if
it's also by the people and that was
that was sort of the conclusion that I'd
come to right before I left to go work
in federal government but I also was on
this journey of understanding what it's
like for folks who are less privileged
in our society to work to work with
government and that story really started
with the San Francisco team who worked
with Mayor edley on a problem again most
of us probably don't have enough access
to which is a the problem of enrolling
in food stamps this is the application
process or part of the application
process for CalFresh our state's
Nutrition Assistance Program there are
over 50 screens and at the end of it you
can print it it's at the end you'll get
a call and still have an interview and
that so this this is part of the problem
that they identified with the problem
they were actually looking at is that
once you if you make it through all of
those several hundred questions um and
actually get enrolled in the program and
start receiving these benefits you will
get an EBT card that looks a lot like a
credit card and typically you will be on
it for about a month and a half and then
you will fall off the rolls and this is
extremely expensive for government
because this is not easy on the user but
it's also not easy on the government
bureaucrat who is processing these forms
so when you've spent all the energy to
get someone rolled and they fall right
off and have to do it all over again
it's a very inefficient process they say
can you help us with this problem of
churn it makes it great do you know why
there's this problem of Turin I said
well we don't exactly know but the the
fellows actually enrolled in the program
so that they could experience what food
stamp recipients were experiencing and
the first thing they found is that you
start to get letters in the mail from
the food stamps office that reads
something like this and I like torturing
people forgive me I'm going to read this
to you for a minute your food stamp
benefit
in this quarter did not change as a
result of the documents last information
that we received because it would not
have resulted in an increase in benefits
your food stamp benefits in this quarter
did not change the result of the
document / information we received in
the new world because the new rule says
that when you report some changes the
county cannot lower your food stamps
until the next quarter the county has
reconfigured your food stamps using
information you reported in the food
stamp amounts nukka it goes on and on
like this there's pages of these things
and you get them really often now some
are embedded in one of these letters is
the notice that you're supposed to send
them some additional piece of
documentation are they going to drop you
from the rolls and no one reads the
letters and if you do read the letters
you don't know that that's what they're
asking for and this is why people were
falling off the rolls did I torture you
enough do you let me to keep reading um
so we got a lot of letters like this it
was super fun but what happens when you
don't read that letter and you don't
comply is that you have this lovely EBT
card and you go to the checkout counter
to get your food and you're the first
person you finally get to the front of
the line and your groceries are all
bagged up at this point and they slide
your card and it goes in and you're not
going home with those groceries and the
people behind you in line are going
what's wrong with the you know the
welfare mom in front of me so you're
both humiliated and hungry and the data
show that a significant proportion of
food stamp benefits are spent at
midnight on Wednesdays because that's
when the food the EBT cards are
recharged who goes shopping at midnight
well probably college to other than you
people who are hungry go shopping at
midnight so these are people there again
this is another time where you can say
you're looking at the data and what
you're seeing is a person in need who
can't get what they need because of bad
government interfaces so this is the
moment that that team that I showed
before this set of developers and
designers doing a year of service chose
to focus in on how could we keep the
woman or the man at the front of the
line from having that your card is
denied moment
and they try to hold in two different
things for several months they tried
putting of websites explaining the
process they had translations of the
letters and that didn't really work they
tried a couple of other things and
finally they landed on the notion that
we could just text people they now tend
what they say turns out and all those
several hundreds of questions and those
50 screens in the application that you
saw earlier there isn't a question that
asks for your cell phone number so they
actually had to do a call athan in order
to do a pilot of this where they got
permission to call a subset of CalFresh
users and ask them for their cell phone
numbers and ask them the permission to
text them and then they piloted a
program where if you were about to fall
off of the roles we would text you your
Cal fash benefits stop at the end of
this month questions please call us and
they found that about forty percent of
people did call and then didn't fall off
the roll so that's pretty significant
intervention that's what they were able
to do believe it or not in almost an
entire year of work at Code for America
with all of the barriers that came into
it and it was a very successful program
that they're continuing to work on but
in investigating this problem they found
so many other problems that they really
needed to work on there because of the
process I showed you there are at least
three and a half million people who in
California are eligible for food for
CalFresh but not getting the pro the
benefits there's about 20 million
dollars a year spent by food stamp
recipients in ATM fees which go directly
to the banks that have already charged
the program it's long story and when you
call the office you will typically wait
on hold for about 45 minutes before you
can talk to a caseworker so these are
small things but what they really got to
understand because they were enrolling
these programs and talking to people is
that these big things really add up even
just things like the fact that you go to
the office and you're asked to fill out
a form using a very short pen on a wall
that's not even flat
this is the kind of its this is maybe
the analog of the digital experience but
this is sort of what we're putting
people through all the time and so they
said let's actually go and that these
fellows decided to stay on and work with
us on this problem let's actually go try
to sort of a surround set of features
that will actually make this experience
better so remember this this long
application how about this is this a
little bit better this is running on an
average mobile phone it's about seven
steps you can then sign it and you're
done now you've enrolled in food stamps
you can put these on iPads and now
caseworkers all over the city of San
Francisco are taking them to people who
they know are eligible and just having
them sign up right there which just
reduces so much the very getting them
into the office and getting them through
these 50 screens what's another one you
don't know how to use your your your
benefits you that you don't know where
who actually takes them well this is it
again I'm basic smartphone in about two
seconds it will say the closest place to
you that will accept your food chances
here this isn't it really important when
people don't know how much is on those
cards and it's a sort of long-term care
is to call in and check your balance
just sort of hack together a thing where
if you text your the code on your EBT
card in will return you actual balance
on your card really quickly and this one
is really key it's very simple if you
are on hold for 45 minutes and you're on
a bt you probably don't have an
unlimited plan and you also don't have
45 minutes who had her as 45 minutes for
that but this will just text it in love
its office will call you back when
there's a caseworker who can talk to you
i know i am not wowing any of you
engineering students with complicated
technology but i hope i'm describing
something that really makes a difference
in the life of somebody who needs a
little bit of a break by the way we just
did this work we didn't actually have to
get permission from the city of San
Francisco we just sort of do these
projects and throw them over the wall
with me through this one over the wall
and leo o Farrell who runs the SNAP
program for San Francisco said
this is great but one thing I have to be
the voice that the caseworker here's
when when connect makes this connect
because it they need to they want to
hear this is your boss Leo or Pharaoh
please hold the line I have a client
waiting to speak with you otherwise the
caseworkers would hang up so the
enthusiasm in government's you know
people really must understand that but
there's a huge enthusiasm for these
these creative hacks to make things work
better the important thing though is
we're getting beyond those creative
hacks this work has enabled us we've now
been invited by the state of California
to actually come work on the core
eligibility system that runs all of
these programs which by the way is a 500
million dollar contract with a vendor
and the the program is written in cobalt
and we have another ten years I think
are worried somewhere in a ten year
contract to maintain a very large COBOL
application but we're going to help them
so this is sort of a way of surrounding
these folks but they're just a bunch of
little hacks just to make their day a
little bit easier but what really it is
is it's a set of things driven by
understanding the user need and this is
the thing that art / arches all of our
experience at Code for America and also
ties us back to those that government
digital service in the UK that I talked
about earlier that's been so successful
why have they been so good at breaking
the big IT cartel about so successful in
delivering government digital services
that really work for the British
citizens not because they had some magic
sauce not because they knew the right
technology stack not because they had
authority though they did have that but
because they had a set of designs
principles that were the right
principles and they got agreement around
them all of them are really valuable and
these are valuable I think not just for
government design their I think they're
valuable for any kind of service design
that any of you in the room may be doing
or will do in the future but I want to
call it the first one in particular
because it says start with needs and
then there's a little asterisks and it
says user needs not government needs
that asterisk says it all I've spent
enough time in government to tell you
that your day is dominated by government
needs and those are things like
compliance and regulations that I
understand why they've come about they
serve an important purpose and I don't
mean to denigrate them in any way but it
means that 99% of your time is spent
meeting those needs instead it instead
of meeting the need of an actual user
they have made sure that that governs
everything that they do that is how it
we try to make sure that that governs
how our fellows and other staff work
when we are doing government design and
that's how you come up with let's
actually make this work for people on
food stamps because you actually care
that that person not have to go home
with no food just to feed their family
so I have this is our mission statement
for the organization we believe that
government can work for the people by
the people of fun in the 21st century
but only if we make it so and we never
mean we Code for America we mean we the
people we mean you we mean it is our job
no one else is going to fix government
for us but I also think that sometimes
the the people can be a little bit
grandiose because what really saying is
government can work for actual real
people who are our neighbors and our
friends and by actual real people who
are us and our neighbors and our friends
ah that that's really what we're saying
and I don't think we would do this work
if we weren't driven by that
understanding um I want to return to the
oh I did have that slide in great so the
this this connection to those real
people which I saw so clearly with those
folks trying to help people on food
stamps and so so clearly with the
amazing team that saved healthcare gov
um really drives really drives this
story of government technology to a
happier ending and so while of course it
was an absolute disaster for a long time
the team really did pull it out I love
love this headline healthcare.gov is
slightly less
durable today ads play it plan preview
feature that occasionally works and of
course in the end of the day we enrolled
more people in health care than we even
thought was possible before the site had
broken but the real in the story is i
went to government I went into federal
government to try to create what I call
them the American digital service and we
did it succeed in that we got Mikey
Dickerson to stay to actually lead this
effort and we do now have an equivalent
to that government digital service in
the UK it's called the USD s and the
best technologist in the country are
leading it we have also published what
we call the u.s. digital services
playbook which has again not just a
playbook for government digital services
a playbook for anybody who wants to
create services that work and it's
against art starts with understanding
what people need and address the whole
experience number four is one that I
have worked on a lot particularly during
the time that I was there the ability to
build services using agile and iterative
processes the Federal Acquisition
regulation is a 2800 page document that
determines how we build and by
technology it's not very agile and it
doesn't allow it has not particularly
loud for iteration but we actually
worked with the office of federal
procurement policy in the time that I
was there to publish the tech far
handbook which reinterprets the rules of
the Federal Acquisition regulation
there's not only reinterpretations an
interpretation to actually say that we
want to use our contractors to support
an iterative and customer driven
software development process and the
reason I bring this up is because I need
you all to be perfectly clear that if
you want to do the kind of work that you
would do at a google or a start-up or
wherever you might go to practice your
engineering or design skills you can
actually do that work in the federal
government now there are no more excuses
and you couldn't you can certainly do
them at the local level two it's not
always easy but we have done the hard
work not that we're done with it but we
have done it most important early hard
work to make sure that you can practice
those skills in the service of the
country
um it is so important to me that you
understand that and that you understand
this as hopefully a part of your career
as it evolves over time because
government has not thought about the
digital as a core part of what it does
for far too long and we're paying the
cost of it when healthcare.gov shipped
and failed on october first was probably
a couple days afterwards when I'm so
we're getting my head around what that
meant I thought back to a blog post that
my colleague Tom Steinberg in the UK had
published this is back in February 2012
he had written a post memorializing a
colleague of his who had died five years
earlier who was a genius and a polymath
and could have done anything in the
world with his skills but had chosen to
use his talents on essentially Civic
technology my society is kind of like
the Code for America of the UK and he
wanted people to understand what that
meant so that his passing you know that
his life still had meaning to the
community around him and when tom is
writing about it he said what what Chris
fundamentally had right was the
understanding that you can no longer run
a country properly if the elites don't
understand technology in the way that
they grasp economics or ideology or
propaganda and his analysis and
predictions about what would happen if
the elites couldn't learn were savage
and depressingly accurate you wrote that
in 2012 before healthcare.gov failed and
before we all realized that if we passed
immigration reform it too would probably
fail on implementation because of our
systems because we have thought for so
long that the people who should go into
government are lawyers and economist
essentially we must have a native
digital capability in order to govern I
know I'm preaching to the choir here but
uh I do think it's we all have a duty to
explain this to others it's not just
technology right the good what good
governance and the good society look
like is now inextricably linked to an
standing of the digital and I think that
is a burden that your generation bears
to explain that and to bring that into
this one institution that is designed to
serve not some of us but all of us let's
see so another way of saying this is not
just the government can for the people
but the government can work but only if
we make it so so with that I encourage
you to of course get involved with code
for america in any way that you would
like and if you have questions about
working at any level of government I
would be delighted to answer them thank
you very much any question yes yes the
question was we've done some interesting
initiatives at the local level and how
are we scale up to the national level um
well one example of that would be enough
scaling up really to the state level at
this point is our work with the
California Department social services
where they've noticed our user centered
and iterative approach and said this is
obviously what's needed you know you
could go state city by city county by
county and try to do this for users or
you can come to us and we'll hit all
whatever is at 38 California counties so
we're sort of going up the stack a
little bit there I mean if this this
movement is still pretty early I think
one of the early indications that these
things scale is simply that about a year
and a half after we created Code for
America a new form of public service for
technologists the federal government did
the same right so some of it is just
sort of passing the baton baton back and
forth on the real thing that actually
unites them is data data flows up from
the local level to the state to the
federal government and back down the
more that we can create a VAP eyes and
find ways to break the silo
in that data and have you know be able
to build our own interfaces to these
services and into the data the more we
will see national scale things and that
work is relatively nascent I guess in
the scheme of things but coming along
quite well yes if I wanted to bid on
these contracts thing to bid to build
halter healthcare.gov what would prevent
me or my company from doing that
technically what was the biggest thing
is so technically nothing in but I'm
sorry what would prevent you personally
or a company that you might found from
bidding on something like healthcare gov
or another government contract the
answer is a you would need to have a
pretty robust muscle in your company for
government procurement and compliance if
you had that that's great in many cases
though you also already need to have
been in business for several years that
this is some of the rules that we're
trying to change you would need to have
a history of government contracts which
makes no sense right like I mean there's
it kind of sometimes gets down to the
nitty-gritty where it's like it's you
know there's so much regulation one of
our colleagues complaints who does work
for the federal government that he every
area is to certify that his bathrooms
are labeled properly like I don't know
why we care but apparently we do that
you can do it and i think that the
barriers are coming down because there
is a clear understanding at the federal
level and at the local level that those
barriers are getting us the results that
are unacceptable to the american public
into the politicians but you know
there's a whole host of them that
generally fall into the buckets of
compliance in a procurement i had
nothing to say about that that is
slipping my mind now but there in that I
guess what I would say is despite those
things we have any
huge explosion of what we call civic
startups right now companies that are
doing it anyway that are figuring out
the procurement stuff that are finding
the innovators in government who will
guide them through the process we've had
30 companies go through the code for
america accelerator incubator and start
tackling the government market and and
just having frankly great success so
don't let my my negativity scare you off
it's still very worthwhile and it's
partly worthwhile because the size of
that market government contracts are
very large you can bid for half or less
of what the competitors are bidding and
still have quite a lovely profit margin
on this work there's also a ton of
business models for civic startups that
don't rely on government contracts
companies like see click fix that works
with local government they do get some
of their revenue from from government
but they have a very robust consumer
model to where they're just interfacing
with the citizen this map is their
advertising revenue there yeah ever did
advertising revenue based models we're
kind of going going right it huge wide
range of different business models for
civic startups of which government
contracts is just one that's right there
is actually now for the first time ever
a venture capital fund devoted
exclusively to Thurman technology run by
a fantastic guy who's been a mentor to
us for several years named Ron booga
name it's a 25 million dollar fund
called ego thing called the gov tech
fund thank you if you're next sir what
why did you decide to do a non-profit as
a model and what challenges did that
have for you for fun we decided to do a
non-profit because i was asking at the
time for some of the most talented
people in the country to work for
thirty-five thousand dollars a year and
i felt like we should probably make sure
that you know that they felt like their
efforts were going to something that was
that was at its foundation charitable
and mission driven and i haven't
regretted that decision honestly grant
funding was a great way to get this
thing started we certainly have a
significant bit of our
avenue for Code for America does come
from governments now so it's not
exclusively funded by philanthropy and I
think that's probably part of our future
but I like us being a nonprofit actually
quite a bit thank you I think we had one
right up here oh you're at the same
thing okay great in the back so the
organization is called Code for America
yet lots of other countries have exactly
the same problems and it seems like it's
kayla puts like very scalable from
ultimate respect what is your
organization kind of doing a lot of your
thoughts on scaling this out to a more
global kind of initiative yes so we've
been contacted by some double-digit
percentage of countries on the planet
about this they do pretty much all have
the same problems in different degrees
you know we're a couple of years old and
opening up offices around the country
seemed like a bit of a leap we've taken
an approach sort of a page from Teach
for America which we obviously reference
in our name who decided also not to
expand globally but to create a
coordination effort across across local
efforts to do the same thing so we
actually of a program called code for
all that helps connect the efforts of
code for Mexico code for the Caribbean
code for Germany I mean those are the
three were working most closely with but
I think there's 50 or 60 groups in in
that network that are all helping each
other and by the way we learn as much
from their efforts as they do from us so
which in it truly is about you know just
expanding the experimentation surface
yes um what would you think about taking
this type of talk to some of the people
that are actually using the services
like in CalWORKs for example some of the
women or men that are involved in that
program and so since its coding for the
people by the meaningful
the people that are actually using it
can learn to increase their income or
having a similar talk there at the book
their offices or some of those
employment places where they can you
know pursue writing or LED lighting
peons because they're actually i'm using
the services i think i understand your
questions so people who are using the
services might actually learn to code or
design and be part of the solution
absolutely and I think our new work and
economic development has a very big
component of this where we're realizing
that if you're going to increase the
economic vitality of any city in this
country a lot of what you're going to
need to do is to help a wider swath of
your community have digital skills
that's not particularly what we do so
there's organizations like code org and
many other positions like hack the hood
that are helping folks actually learn to
code what we are doing generally is
helping on the bureaucratic side where
for instance you may have a workforce
development program that is simply
inefficient and badly implemented in
terms of its interface and we can help
we can help fix that but it is
absolutely part of the program and it
just take another answer to another
question if that's okay yeah just
basically it's not saying a lot about
this kind of salt columns on
case-by-case basis mm-hmm and yet a lot
of the problems it seems like the
unknown problem some of these other
problems stem from the lack of
understanding which I felt yet going
okay so I'm just be curious given your
experience and go projects as well how
do you think we
kind of the next gender go about that
wonder one which is a lack of
understanding go so a the fundamental
problem is a lack of understanding of
Technology and government could not
agree more how do we go about changing
that wide variety of different answers
to that I think you know one of the
things that I would love to see is that
by five years from now everybody with
great digital skills in our country not
just in the Stanford community the
startup community feels that there is an
expectation that they will do service
too in government for some period of
time I'm not saying that everybody needs
to go have a full career in government
though I think many have decided to do
that and not regretted it have felt
enormous satisfaction from their work
but I think a critical component of it
is especially if your aspiration is to
go build a start-up and have commercial
success after you have an exit there's a
year or two where you should go work in
government great great models for this
right now yasha Franklin Hodge who was
one of the cofounders of blue state
digital a which helped get Barack Obama
elected is now the CIO of Boston I can I
think in this time I won't give my long
litany of other examples but there's
also just ways to get involved with this
movement being a fellow mentoring
startups you know doing a civic startup
yourself I'm sure you would all agree
this has been incredibly inspiring
please join me in thanking I
you